good
morning and welcome to the spectators
alternative conference streaming live on
spectator tv
my name is matthew kilcoin and i'm the
deputy director of the adam smith
institute i'm privileged to be joined
this morning for a debate about
canada australia new zealand and the uk
a new union by the leader of the
official opposition of canada erin
o'toole
it's very early where you are aaron so
just after six in the morning so thank
you enormously for joining us
aaron has been the leader of the
conservative party of canada since
august of this year
and was served as minister of veterans
affairs in 2015
and has been a member of the parliament
for durham since 2012
and made kansas a key plank of his offer
to the conservative party members in the
leadership election this year
also joining us are alicia kearns the
conservative mp for rutland and melton
elected in december of last year and who
is the deputy chair of the appg
on kanzak and finally we're joined in
what is the evening for him by senator
james patterson
an australian senator representing the
state of victoria senator patterson is
the chair of both the joint
parliamentary committee
on corporations and financial services
and the senate finance and public
administration legislation committee
which is
a hell of a hell of a mouthful for
spending a lot of money
uh and deputy chair of the senate select
committee on covid 19 an important man
so he was also the only federal
politician in australia to publicly
support brexit prior to the 2016
referendum
and he's the author of a ripa deal the
case for free trade and free movement
between australia and the united kingdom
which we released at the adam smith
institute earlier this year as well
now kansas has been long known as an
acronym in international circles
and at the united nations where canadian
australia new zealand and uk governments
have acted in tandem on issues for
decades and together make up the non-us
section of the five
eyes intelligence and security sharing
community
however movements have recently set up
in each state at the civil society level
to push for greater freedoms for the
citizens of each to live and work
between the other states
they argue that canada australia and new
zealand and the uk each share
the same language the same westminster
parliamentary system the same respect
for common law and the same sovereign
the four modern states are liberal
diverse mature democracies that trust
one another
whose citizens are well integrated and
feel at home
in each so is it time to update the
rights of citizens to mass
match the aspirations and the comfort of
what is a proposition
whose time has come or is it something
that's looking into the past
so what i will do is i'll stand up as a
as we look to
uh britain leaving the european union
and finally at the end of this year and
also
looking at what the relations of this
whole country should be
in a ever regionalizing world i'll ask
aaron o'toole to send out why he made it
such a key pillar of his campaign
to members of the conservative party of
canada earlier this year
well thank you very much matt it's a
pleasure for me to join here early in
the morning
from canada and uh
the very fact that we have james uh
in australia in the evening alicia and
yourself in the uk myself here
uh talking about kanzak talking about a
modern version of the anglosphere
reminds me of
the old expression the sun never sets on
the british empire
and feels like that with the
participation we have
with uh everyone on here tonight and
look
i i've been talking about kanzak for
over three years now
uh like many good tory leaders i didn't
win the first time i ran for the
leadership
of the tory party here in canada i
placed third out of 15 or so
characters uh in the last race and
really the
the policy that resonated the most from
my
campaign three years ago was kansa and
it grew mainly out of
um conversations i'd had here in in
canada
sparked by the brexit debate
in uh in the uk and canada had just
finalized under prime minister harper a
european
free trade agreement between canada and
the eu
and there were already discussions here
in canada about what
we would do post-brexit
to ensure that our closest relation
out of the previous deal with ceta
what would we do with the uk in the
in the in the event that the brexit vote
happened we had the ceta agreement but
we didn't have a standalone
uk agreement and what was remarkable at
the time for me
was there was a young expat brit living
in vancouver of all places
james skinner who had started an online
movement called
kansak international and so when i was
in vancouver james and i sat down
and it was remarkable to see how much
grassroots
interest amongst all the countries there
was
for a an update to the anglo-sphere or
an update to the commonwealth 2.0
in the in the era of brexit and in the
era
where i like to say we need aspirational
multilateralism where we have
closely aligned countries that share
like values share a history a language a
commitment to the rule of law and
parliamentary democracy
to do more together at a time
where many people are seeing uh
international multilateral work becoming
a race to the bottom
at some of the international fora so the
the concept of a kansak
which has been out there for for decades
in various forms
was very appealing particularly to young
people where there's the ability to
to live work have the free exchange of
people
capital ideas and to show that
multilateralism
can be a force for good when it comes to
security and and opportunity for the
peoples
of australia new zealand the uk and
canada i used to say it's it's
it's four of the five eyes which is our
closest alignment of intelligence
sharing and security cooperation
so i've been talking about it for many
years and when i ran for
leader again it of course became
centerpiece to my
to my policy campaign and i really think
right now canada is at a disadvantage
with prime minister trudeau
because these conversations in various
forms are happening
post-brexit with australia and new
zealand and sadly
under our current prime minister
canada's
not at the table whatsoever so if if
canada will be we're in a minority
parliament here in canada we will have
an election probably sometime in the
next six
months uh our party the tory party in
canada is pledging
uh to be a participant in a in a kansa
type
agreement between the countries it will
be centerpiece in terms of our platform
and i'm certainly optimistic that we
have a very good chance of winning the
next election
and then joining our our allies in
discussions about really
taking this relationship to the next
level at a time where i think it's
it's desperately needed so there's a lot
of interest here in canada and
that's why i'm up at the crack of dawn
to talk about it today
and thank you very much for doing that
and i i know
that actually it's an official plank of
your campaign
and uh thank you for also bringing up
you know the current prime minister and
whether he's actually doing enough
it's also an official policy of the
nationals but in uh new zealand and
act as well in new zealand so it's
becoming a bit more of
the scene out there um alicia
in the uk conservative party um
it's been an issue that's been growing
and growing the recent apbg's
the backbench group on this has just
been set up how likely is this an idea
that could be taken up by the leadership
at the uk conservative party i mean this
is an idea that has to be taken up by
the leadership and
i'm all to creating that future alliance
that erin set out so beautifully
um you know there was real passion for
this within the party
there's real passion from within the
country you know the advancement
institute has done research on this it
shows that to be the case
and it's really interesting because the
only aunties i hear the only apologists
are essentially uk labour party mps who
suggested some kind of
neo-colonial white nationalist project
which is just so
completely offensive in every single way
you know we are countries that embrace
diversity and multiculturalism
you know look at the eu project that's
made up of 27 mainly white countries and
no one would ever suggest such a thing
and so i'm really keen that we are
robust on this and step four and say
this is a really fascinating time of
opportunity for our nation
we need to step up we need to embrace it
we need to cast off the shackles of
people who are trying to make us
apologists
for the friends that we keep um and we
do have incredible affinity
you know i don't think there's any
nations in the world that have the
affinity that the kansas ones do
and as erin said in a time where you
know we need to stand strong from
values the international rule of law
it's really important that kansas exists
not only so that uk can take its place
in the world stage as an independent
nation
but so that western liberal nations can
fight together stand together
in trade diplomatically in military
circles
and standstill of what we believe in and
we all recognize that this is a time
where we under
threat from hybrid warfare and actually
cancer can work together on science
on space on education there are so many
things that we already do work together
you know it's australia that all my
friends were experts in space are going
over to earth to work on
you know we need to make the most you
know when i was uh
when i was in the military the global
coalition against irish which of course
all kansas members are
whenever i was in the military base
anywhere in the world it was the kansas
colleagues that came together
not just for socializing but actually
for working together because
we have a natural affinity the same
values the same kind of priorities
and why would you throw away such an
affinity
and i think that's the recognition
that's coming together in the
conservative party as we start to stand
strong and say
we have a new future we have a new
opportunity
and kansak absolutely has to be a
central tenant of that
thank you very much james the
we've got bojo in number 10 we've got
scomo in camera
camera they ran on very similar
electoral platforms they're very similar
in terms of outlook
on what life mean have we got an
opportunity with the fta
is it being taken advantage of well
enough by the two governments with so
close
affinities um to deliver the promise of
kansas
that people want both in australia and
the uk
thanks matt and can i just say at the
outset what a pleasure it is to be on a
panel with
alicia and with aaron they're two
parliamentarians who are admired greatly
for their advocacy not just of this
issue but actually
a concern that the three of us share
very closely as well which is the
chinese communist party and we could
just as easily be on a panel with the
three of us talking about that as well
and although it's not the topic of
today's discussion
i think it's an underlying factor which
is contributing to the resurgence of
this idea and the popularity of this
idea
i'm a free trader i want australia to
trade with every country in the world
but
i want our economic relationships to be
particularly close
with our long-standing trusted friends
and allies with people who
we share values with with people who we
would never fear
they would use our trade against us
who'd never engage in economic coercion
against us which unfortunately
the chinese communist party is doing and
in an age of rising authoritarianism
then finding like-minded allies but
binding together and working together is
a sensible thing to do
what i think some people don't
appreciate is that the building blocks
are really there for a kansas agreement
australia already effectively has a
kansas agreement just with new zealand
we have complete freedom
of movement of people uh and of trade
and capital there's no
barriers between us the world trade
organization has called that trade
agreement the best trade agreement in
the world
both new zealand and australia are right
now negotiating free trade agreements
with the uk
all we need to do is add canada to that
and effectively the building blocks are
there
and it wouldn't take much effort at all
to link those four trade agreements up
between each country and call it cancer
and have that agreement so
we're closer than we've ever been we
know it's now possible because of brexit
the challenge is to seize the
opportunity i think there's real
growing uh groundswell of support for it
here in australia as
aaron said it's particularly exciting
for young people who want to have those
opportunities to
travel and study and work in like-minded
countries with the same language and
legal system and political culture
the challenge is just to seize that
opportunity and i think we're very very
close
and aaron how do you think that the
kansas state should try and respond to
to china as a as a threat
well great point and uh it's my pleasure
to share the stage with
with like-minded uh friends and i will
just build on one of james points
it is very easy if there would be some
leadership on the canadian front because
australia new zealand canada were part
of the trans-pacific partnership talks
together
in terms of trade and and the while the
us withdrew the rest of us had been at
the table
and of course the relationships between
australia and new zealand and canada
within
that larger block of trade discussions
were were very strong
even though we had some issues like milk
and other dairy products
uh as as rubs the the relations were
always strong
going on to to china uh i think this is
another
reason for it i agree with james this is
part of an underlying wider interest
in kanzuk at this time because of the
global disruption caused by the
communist party of china and how they
have used
trade in a predatory fashion
and it it has been interesting for
canada to watch the the leadership of
australia
to be honest with you in terms of being
in the immediate sphere of influence
and being much more straight up with
respect to concerns about beijing
all the countries have deep concerns
with what's happening
in in hong kong canada and world war
ii we lost lost our our sons there
trying to defend
uh hong kong we had two battalions that
tried desperately to fend off the
japanese so
we all have deep personal ties there's
300 000
canadian citizens who live in hong kong
there's more we call it our 10th
province there's more
uh canadians living in hong kong than in
our small province of prince edward
island for example
so i i think that prime minister trudeau
has been remarkably mute
on this subject and i think australia
in in some ways has been the the at the
forefront of the kansas countries in
terms of
pushing for a stronger international
response
and i think it's having an effect i
remember even conversations between
alicia and i
with respect to huawei i think the the
five eyes and the kanzak should have
taken a united position
on the participation of huawei in our 5g
critical infrastructure networks and
i really do think that the positions
taken by
by australia new zealand eventually
influenced the uk's decision along with
the back bench
i think uh influencing the decision
canada of course is still sitting out
there having not made a decision
so i think with china's china's
tradition
of trying to isolate countries and apply
pressure
through this the size of their economic
clout
the more we have this alignment uh on
critical issues like huawei
actually helps us weather that that
tactic
from china so i do think this is
probably the most
compelling reason for why we have to
turn kanzak
from a great concept into a reality
and speaking of the reality and james
the
um how would the flow of people look
like
uh one of the things that we've we've
seen in the brexit debate was concerns
over
large numbers of people who maybe lived
a
different lifestyle different cultures
from other groups of people whether the
pace of change was
uh acceptable or not to voters what what
was the
like realistic risk like what doesn't
what does that kanzak union end up
looking like to the average ended case
at the average citizen in each of your
states and so we start with the uk first
it's really important that the
conservative party indeed every party
in the uk pretty much is pro-immigration
it's about having the right immigration
immigration that bolsters us not just
economically
but also bolsters us in terms of
culturally and kind of opportunities for
our nation to grow
with kansak i think a lot of the
questions or concerns about migration go
out the window because we already have
as aaron and james have said these
shared values these shared concepts of
the rule of law
our democratic systems are very similar
we share the same suffering
you know i believe that i think the most
sensible way ahead given the uk
set out will be going with the points
would it be a specific visa i think
that's really the most sensible way to
go ahead
um because obviously given that we've
decided to go with that model i think
it's free movement doesn't necessarily
come
naturally to that uh i would be in that
support
nation so i think the most sensible and
problematic and this is my trans
handsome travel model but moving it to a
kind of specific candidate visa
and james how do you think in australia
how do you think australia as a
political reality would respond
to the idea like the more generally more
the idea of
increasing well there's a better
advantagement agreements also include
canada in the uk
exactly i mean that's the key point that
is that australia already has this
relationship with new zealand and it
works remarkably well uh kiwis are an
integrated part of australian life
and in fact even without this agreement
with the uk there's about a million
uh people of uk descent living in
australia so i don't think much would
change from our point of view actually
what would probably happen more easily
is young australians going to london
to have that experience that they
historically used to have uh in the in
the last century
but which has dropped dramatically in
the last 20 years as a result of
the uk's legitimate desire to control
its immigration
but its previous inability to restrict
it from eu member states which means
its only ability to restrict it has been
to non-eu member states like australia
and i think that's been a really
perverse outcome where australians who
are by yougov polls
the most popular type of migrant and
visitor to the uk
have been the ones that have suffered
the most through eu membership of the uk
so getting out of the eu gives you the
opportunity to control those things
control over your trade and control over
your immigration
and why not pick other countries like
australia and canada
where there's so much income and not
just language and culture and common
understanding
but respect for the rule of law that we
know and similar levels of economic
development that we know that
our migrants are going to move freely
between each of those four jurisdictions
uh really without any trouble at all and
also i just add matt
we have to remember that 80 percent more
brits live in kansas nations that live
in the eu
and that's the site that people don't
talk about and it just makes it so
obvious when you say that
that kansas is where british people want
to live when they live abroad
and so therefore we have to facilitate
that and make it easier for them to come
to the uk as well
that's only true it's one of those
things where we talk about sort of the
gravity model of trade actually
there's a gravity model of immigration
as well you
you you move where you have family links
where you have your anti-valve live or
your cousin lives already
and even if you're from a british indian
background caribbean background
uh cantonese background you're more
likely to have family members who live
in australia new zealand and canada
than you do with or anywhere else that
the uk currently has very little
operational as well
um in terms of we talk about you know in
many ways obviously you're all from
parties of the right um realistically if
this is to become an issue that is
settled
as a national project for each of the
states it has to be a project that
reaches across the aisle
um and aaron in in canada's case it also
has to be a project that reaches quebec
as well as a non-english speaking part
of canada
um how do we do that how do we make sure
that left-wingers and and people who
aren't from an english-speaking
background
um are appealed to as well
well that's a great great point i do
think there's a unique window
right now with with the governments in
australia and the uk
that if we did have a conservative
government join the the club from canada
so to speak
it would facilitate uh discussions
that i think are really easy once once
there's the political will to make them
happen
and within our own country you know
certainly we we have
the the french and english and and uh
quebec traditionally has not had the
same level of affinity with
with uh the monarchy and and that part
of our history but
quebecers are are a free trading uh
um peoples within canada as well and i
think there's
there is a sense that the more we can
have
free trade that's aligned with our
values and that advances
um canadian interests broader than just
economic
interests i think there there is that
interest and i'll tell you
the the cultural ties and connections
are so deep
that i think the the the education
and early work years of the young
citizens of all of our countries
are are the way to make this work i
already think we joke that in in
british columbia the whistler ski resort
is essentially run by
australians in their in their
we've had some degree of student
exchange and student work programs
between the countries
but if we could have this mobility and
perhaps even
having the universities within each of
our countries
treat hansuk members almost like
domestic for tuition purposes or have it
as a preference
over international tuition rates
i think you would see really younger
people taking the lead in terms of
of this opportunity to to
edge be educated to work to gain that
experience
and then potentially return with those
eyes and connections
and i think um quebecers people from all
parts of canada
want that opportunity and this is what i
say when i call it
aspirational multilateralism you're
showing
benefits that that flow to the
individual person
and not just state to state benefits so
i think
i think there would be real interest i i
think also
once the the the negotiations or once
the
loose agreement is in place it would be
so beneficial that there would be no
risk of
in our case the liberal party uh
changing course i know the liberal party
in
australia is is a little different than
our liberal party in canada
but i don't think you would see a change
in government leading to
lack of interest in kanzak i think that
the chances of it being lined up though
through
conservative aligned parties is more
realistic
and james you know building practical
steps treaties aside how do we build
i like the idea of the sort of uh kansas
erasmus that you were sort of mentioning
there and how do we build those civil
society links
uh we'll rebuild them in many respects
after decades of neglect
well matt i was going to make a very
similar point to the point that aaron
just made which is that this
certainly has been a project largely of
the center right politically so far and
it has its best chance
if we get all conservative governments
elected in in canada and new zealand in
their upcoming elections
but it's one of those ideas that once
initiated it would never be reversed it
would be almost impossible to think
that a government would campaign on an
issue of abolishing kansak and taking
away from people
that freedom to travel and to work and
to study
in these like-minded countries and that
in an age where
the world is becoming less stable not
more stable that you would want to drive
a stake between
allies and between like-minded countries
one of the most interesting
things over the last few months is the
way in which the five eyes network has
expanded
its levels of cooperation it was
previously quite a narrow security
focused organization but now the
treasurers and finance ministers of the
five eyes countries
and other key ministers have been having
their own coordination
and on things like hong kong and
xinjiang and other issues with the
chinese communist party have been
issuing
joint statements of concern now that is
essentially the political and foreign
policy element
that's being formed there the only thing
that's missing is the economic element
and i think that's
our task is to secure these agreements
and everything else will build upon that
uh in a funny way what the chinese
communist party is doing
is it's organizing the world against it
by its aggressive approach it is
demonstrating to all of us the things
that we have in common
and the virtues of us working together
and that's particularly important for
middle-sized countries for middle powers
who don't have
the weight of the super power to fall
back on we need to network closer
together in that multilateral way that
aaron is talking about
to secure all of our own sovereignty and
all of our own freedom so
this is the time to seize the
opportunity and
alyssia you are this is really your bag
it's a question from raghav
um and builds on what james was just
saying what are your thoughts on semi
uniting some of the
you know the royal navy's high commands
some of the like port sharing
um some of the sort of military aspects
that allow us to make sure that we're
not just becoming a middle in power
um on the global stage and i know have
we got like is there a level to which
there could be a formal alliance in the
south pacific between the
you know anzac um so uk
before i go into that i just want to
quickly in addition to the points that
erin james made
the one thing we haven't made is we've
made the state for why politicians and
people want it
but we have to remember that businesses
want kansas to work as well
uh all of our businesses want greater
mobility for their workforces
um you know the area has trade value
something like 3.5 trillion dollars
um so i think it's really important we
remember that this isn't just a
political kind of aspirational piece
this is really important for our
businesses for the bottom line
essentially
and it is really important also for
defense i'm not at this point convinced
and aaron and james may disagree with me
that we need a formal
defense agreement because the fact is we
have the firebirds intelligence
and firewise intelligence is is a core
kind of it's a chord that unites every
single piece of work that we do
even when you're working within bigger
kind of political or military alliances
it's still the fires that come together
for separate meetings on the sideline as
erin was saying
we already share high commands we have
five eyes uh
kind of uh uh seconds within pretty much
every single major command that we have
within our ports the level of our work
together military cannot be
underestimated but it is also
not necessarily that well known publicly
um but it is
the most important tenet of our national
security
without question is the five lies
relationship and that is why we have to
invest in it mercilessly we have to be
proud of it we have to protect it
and that's why i'm not necessarily open
to extending it beyond the five eyes at
this point in time
um but absolutely kansak we need
the uk is taking more of an interest in
the south seas for obvious reasons
and that is something that will be
welcomed uh by other cancer partners
but it doesn't need a formal alliance or
partnership to do that
we are already in the right place we
already have the right mechanisms
to support each other wonderful and as
we sort of come to an end now
um i'm just going to hand it back to
each of you for 30 seconds or so to give
me the one
major reason that you think this is a
good idea for each of your countries
uh and maybe create a better union uh
for the future of the world as well
so james i'm going to head to you first
alicia then to you and then aaron finish
up with you
thanks matt very briefly this is an old
idea whose time has come
and as every day moves on and as the
geopolitical environment becomes
less and less certain its need will
become more and more apparent and
supporters will pile on so
we can all say that we were here early
as the support grows from here
uh so this for me is about aspiration
it's about opportunity
it's about affinity it's about trust and
it's about security
and those are five things that all our
nations want all
our nations need and kansaic as james
said
the idea has had its time has finally
come so we need to step forward
this is a time of opportunity for the uk
let's step
forward and not make any mistakes and
grasp the most important opportunities
and affinities before us
aaron as well
well what's interesting i was reading a
few months ago
uh the the iron curtain speech from
winston churchill after he lost the
election right after
uh the end of the world world war ii and
in that speech
right after the formation of the united
nations he warned that if the united
nations
started turning into a bit of a tower of
babel that it was up to the anglosphere
it was up to
uh those english speak speaking peoples
as he would describe
it to to step up and be a counter
balance in global affairs
and i think that time is now
as james has has highlighted so well
the the need for powers to align
to express our our shared commitment to
the rule of law to human rights
and to a rules-based approach to global
trade and other things
i think with the rise of china and and
the failures of the united nations on
on several levels it's up to smart
multilateralism through like-minded
countries and i can't think of a better
grouping
of uh world-leading democracies in
canada australia new zealand
and the uk to do more together how
formalized that is
will really depend on when the parties
come together and speak but i think it's
time
and i think the world needs this type of
multilateralism
uh of an aspirational quality here
yeah thank you so much by the way for
all of you for joining us and for you
joining us
at home as well and it is a real
privilege actually to
to join this is uh as a chair i've been
following this issue for a number of
years and i never thought it would be
one of those issues that actually
uh captured the mainstream attention i
was thought it was going to be one of
those ones that we always did on the
outside but
it's so glad to see it become a major
issue in a major plank of
campaigns right across the world um and
as we
i look forward to your campaign uh aaron
i look forward to you taking it taking
the fight to uh president trudeau
um and ensuring that you know more
canadians hear about this
idea and hopefully um once the election
in
new zealand is finished as well we'll be
able to talk to some kiwis about the
idea as well but um
uh thank you very much james thank you
alyssia thank you aaron for joining us
um and yes winter is coming but kanzuk
is coming too
have a have a nice day everybody